Welcome back to Computer Vision.
Today, we're going to
continue on our long and, and
winding excursion through tracking.
And in particular,
what we're going to do, today,
is we're going to revisit
the whole notion of base,
based fi filter tracking or,
or, or Bayesian tracking.
And sort of develop a method
that allows us to do that well.
So you remember the tracking
with dynamics, right?
So the whole idea was, because we're
tracking something that's moving with
respect to the imagery, we're going to
learn something about the dynamics and
use the dynamics in order
to make predictions.
And we're doing this so that we can
limit the area of search that we're
looking in, and also so that we can
get a better total estimate when
we're done under the assumption that
the things we were trying to track it's,
you can't perfectly detect them and
it's noisy to begin with.
And we're basically making an assumption
that there's some sort of smooth
motion going on and that essentially
our dynamics don't surprise us is,
is the underlying element.
So last time we developed what
was called the Kalman filter.
And the Kalman filter was for
linear dynamical systems,
dynamic systems where you
had Gaussian noise contexts.
So what we meant by that was the motion
could be predicted by a linear
factor applied to the motion that you've
estimated and then you add in some
Gaussian noise, if you were thinking
about what the uncertainties are.
Same thing with our measurements.
They were a linear function of
the state, and then there was noise, and
what was nice about it is everything,
prediction,
correction your lunch break,
it's all Gaussian, all right?
And so the only thing you have
to do is maintain the mean and
the covariances of these Gaussians and
it just works in one d or n d, etc.
It's really easy.
And the calculations are pretty
straightforward also.
I mean the,
the equations looked a little ugly,
but it's just a bunch of matrix
multiplies and a couple of inverses